omar
carradine hello hello hello thanks for
coming on the show my brother thanks for
having me
i love being here i love the setup that
you put together
and i'm just very happy to be here so
thank you for that
i'm grateful for you i'm grateful for
evan bliss for making
our first introduction happen and also
for
make plus all that you're building
i'm so pumped to unpack this maker's
journey
yeah so my of you and also of all the
people that come through
yeah i'm pumped all right
let's uh let's rock it let's rock it
right in
for it yeah we have a journey that
we must unpack so
roots nourishment
okay the seed we're going way back
i love it um okay so i
uh i was born and raised in the middle
east in dubai to be specific
and my both my parents are in
the design field my mom is an interior
designer my dad
sort of helps my mom run the interior
design company kind of takes care of
most of the business side of things
um and i kind of grew up with this like
sort of you know pre-determined
thought that was you know my mom was
always telling me that i see you
you know leading and and sort of
creating these things and putting things
together like that's kind of what i see
for you you know
and i kind of grew up with like hearing
that all the time and it kind of
manifested itself
into you know me maybe doing that um
and then i studied architecture just
because for me it was
uh one of these categories
that will provide you with all the tools
that you need in order to
sort of and i'll say this again later
but bring ideas to life right
i feel like in terms of architecture
specifically
it's too big of a scale for you to go
through the whole process
because of that disconnect between when
you're doing like a big building
you have that section in which you're
sitting down and sort of designing
behind a computer screen and
and putting things together virtually
right um and then there's a disconnect
in which a contractor comes in and then
sort of puts that together and builds it
all
right and then by the time they're doing
that you're sort of moving on and
working on your next
design venture right where the smaller
the scale
specifically with furniture and that's
where all of this kind of started
um you get to go through that process in
its entirety so you can
start by coming up with this idea um
instead of
literally bringing it to life and
putting it together and feeling it and
there's a there's a crazy validation
right in in having this thing that's in
your mind
that then you can tangibly like it's
there you can touch it you can feel it
um and so that's sort of the journey in
which
what it let me manifest this idea of
what i'm trying to do
so again back to i studied architecture
in
the american university of sharjah which
is a
small city right next to dubai um and
then i moved out here about two and a
half
years ago maybe three now um
worked at an architecture firm more of a
design build firm
honestly because i didn't want to lose
that connect of being able to be
because it was a small scale
architecture firm i was able to actually
you know be on site and sort of
go through some of that physical aspect
of the things that i didn't want to lose
if i just fixated on architecture
um and about a year ago i left my job
and started focusing on putting together
this creative hub
make plus which is um our motto is
actually bring your ideas to life
yeah which is where this whole thing
started from yeah right yes and so
that's that's make plus for you yeah
that's how it started
so mom and dad
are still running interior design
business
yes in dubai yes and your
younger brother other siblings or just
younger brother i have a younger brother
and a younger sister
and a younger sister neither one got
interested in
the interior design or
architecting or furniture um
actually my sister is an interior
designer she is she's she's studying
to become an interior designer she's
still in college right now but
she's following she's following me yeah
okay
so then mom and dad had a good amount of
influence
on definitely the star definitely and
also
a good amount of influence on the
bringing of
what it is yes that you know exists
today in
in several ways like we're not
necessarily speaking financially
um but even like i look up to my dad
when it comes to like the business side
of things
a lot because i feel like he's you know
i've seen him
bring several companies to life i've
seen him put together
the structures of these things and and
he's sort of like the business backbone
of everything that we're doing right now
um it's very important for me to mention
that and to just put it out there
um i think it's important to give credit
where it's due yes um and definitely you
know my mother for like
being the person who pushed and sort of
put this idea of
you know leading and and creating and um
being a force a driving force yeah yeah
um bless the nourishment of
really solid parents 100 100
preach preach yeah man that
is such a crucial
piece to
that main analogy from high level
perception that
real first one that's so profound
that seed of the tree getting the
nourishment in the roots that enables it
to flower the fruits is the
similar style idea with the human seed
getting the nourishment of the roots and
especially when both parents
are there and putting in that love and
those basic needs
being met enable the kid to really rock
it up and get some fruits but
there's also interesting archetypes
about you know people's
shadows and some of the darknesses
shadow births fire
these types of things as well along the
way what were kind of like some of your
more harder times growing up
that you can share with us that you
think may be insightful
and how did you find the treasure on the
other side of those traumas
um in terms of like serious trauma
i feel like i'm i'm blessed that i can't
say that i went through anything that
was serious enough to like
impact my life and change my course at
any point in time
um i grew up you know with this idea of
of i love making things i remember that
you know back when i was really young
there was a time
where i would just pick up scraps of
wood and just put them together and
not really know what i was making but it
was just the idea of putting something
together
was fascinating to me um and
my parents kind of sort of caught that
early on and tried to nourish that and
bring that to life
i don't think that there's a specific
trauma that i can pinpoint that's that i
would say you know changed my life or
change
besides the realization that
i studied architecture for five years
you know
um but i didn't want to do architecture
yeah you know and and i wouldn't
classify that as
a trauma or something that's you know
but it was a it was a moment in time
where i realized
that i you know i got i spent these five
years
learning and and capturing all these
tools
that i have but i don't want to put them
in what i was intended to put them
right and there was a point in time
where i didn't know what i could do with
these tools and what i could do with
these things
that could be well first of all
lucrative enough that i can you know
sustain a living
but at the same time um be happy with
what i'm doing and creating
um i know that furniture is not one of
those things
where you can like make a lot of money
and become like a millionaire out of out
of doing furniture and i know that
there's a
an entrepreneurial side to me that wants
to sort of build something
and and and put together all these
little elements that come together to
form this big hole
um which we'll probably get in depth
into um
and so for me i think that switch at
which where i was still
working at the firm that i was working
in here and having to make that decision
to leave that and leave that constant
that was
sort of you know moving me forward and
just
making that switch was a pretty
difficult time
um we call those leaps of faith yeah
yeah exactly well
i took i took quite leap in terms of
like leaving something
and and jumping into this idea that
hadn't yet manifested itself you know
and i
had no idea what it was specifically but
i knew that there was something there
you know something that i had to pursue
and i knew that
there was a certain point at which i
couldn't pursue two things hand in hand
i wasn't able
there was a certain point at which i
couldn't do my job and give it my
hundred percent
and also build this little baby and give
it my hundred percent you know
and so making that switch i feel was a
very
substantial point in my life and there
were there were a lot of times where
you know i thought about it i was like
hey did i did i make the right decision
am i i mean even right now like there
are points in time where i question
you know if it would have been better if
i had just stayed at a steady you know
income
job and i didn't have to worry about all
that but then sitting back and looking
at this thing instead of going through
autopilot
is is pretty like it's validating it's
that same analogy i made
about building furniture and being able
to touch it to see it
you know so that's kind of
one way i would answer that question in
terms of what is the point in time that
you know i had a quick shift yeah i'm
glad that the
parents came in and really nurtured that
moment when they saw you
putting together the wood scraps i think
that
something that may be really interesting
at a macro level phenomenon to
investigate is that
what percentage
of people
that end up having such a bright flame
undergo some sort of shadow which is a
very common
archetype that people talk to me about
all the time
and then there's these fun and i would
say more unique
cases of people like you that were
nurtured by
two parents didn't really seem to have
like tremendous
shadow-esque moments uh lack of
nutrients type moments
and that still end up having a very
bright fire and i i would hypothesize
that one of them
is that uh you're a f you're
you're proving yourself as the first
sort of generation
immigrating into the united states to
pursue their dreams in the code of law
and the artistic community that we have
here entrepreneurial
yeah so that's usually a big one for you
know myself as well
uh that being the case as being born
here but
being from that first generation
immigrant family and that's a very
common theme
in the first generation immigrant
families as well so
that'd be an interesting percentage to
analyze and the other thing that i
thought that you said that was
interesting was that
we typically don't think that when we go
into
architecture that the architecture is
going to be doing some sort of
3d model and then we're going to hand it
off and then it's going to get built
and then we're not even going to see it
or touch it or do the building at all
that's a that's an important point to
make because
maybe we do need architects to
definitely
be more involved in like you said with
furniture you're
you're right there physically making it
along with the
after the modeling process and maybe
maybe architects actually going in and
working
with that process more hands-on
is will would would be potentially
sometimes more
rich for them to at least connect back
to
to that along along the journey and and
and
overall i think there is going to be a
bigger synthesis with
things like what we talked about with
evan and what we're going to talk about
with you
is that architecting is not even
limited to buildings and offices but
architecting is the word that we use
when we talk about building the future
we talk about architecting civilization
we talk about civilization design
so that's probably one of my favorite
ways to use that word
so i'm not i'm not gonna you know i'm
not gonna sit here
and talk about architecting the
inclusive stakeholding
decentralized protocols and then for me
to
just be like well now other people can
go and build that
you know i want to be there like that's
the whole thing
you 3d model it and then you want to be
there hands-on
watching observing creative directing
all this type of stuff
and engaging engineering all that stuff
it's it's really important i appreciate
that point too i'd like to also
say we i mean we we've had this
conversation a while back and we talked
about like what is
architecture right yeah and this is a
very common conversation
in you know the architecture field right
we talk about it a lot and we try to
answer that question and i feel like
there's a lot of people with different
perspectives on what that means
um but one definition that i've heard
which which makes a lot of sense to me
is that arc
architecture is simply creating
relationships between elements
um i remember saying that to you and it
kind of just clicked in your head
right yeah because it's not limited to
you know architecture as a practice as
architecture in the sense that it's
it's just this thing where you you
model buildings and build buildings and
it's houses and things like that
architecture is just creating
relationships between elements
right we are architecting a scenario
right now
where we are creating something that
other people are engaging into and
seeing and and
benefiting from and we are benefiting
from all that and this is
a form of architecting right yes um so
that's just the small point that i'd
like to point out
it's a massive point and i'm really
happy that you brought it back in
because it was a big
moment for me creating relationships
between elements
so the last couple of days on the
program
and even with jeanette just a little bit
ago on the show
we dove into the idea of
connections and relationships being
fundamental to consciousness
and just in re in reality in general
subatomic particles and math
and humans and countries and all levels
the macro
meso and micro you get what
we would say are those relationships and
connections and the way that they
describe
the relationship between two elements
and so
that is so fundamental to the nature of
reality it's
unbelievable how fundamental it is and
it's
so beautiful to to think about the
it beyond just the trust of a building
and the relationship of the the plumbing
to the electrical
but the relationship of the uh
the way that a a
a mother tree will sequester
carbon more carbon undergo more
photosynthesis produce more sugars
distribute them through the mycorrhizal
networks to
fungi into smaller seedlings in the
understory and then the
the fungi will in the relationship
sequester out nitrogen phosphorus
potassium water and distribute those to
the trees
so that same style of relationship
between humans being
architected in the decentralized
decentralization and the protocol layer
is going to be really instrumental given
tokenomics and mechanism design
to move us more towards inclusive
stakeholding to move us more towards
where we're actually linked up more like
we are where i'm taking a breath right
now
you're taking a breath the audience is
taking a breath 20
000 breaths per day and there's a
relationship an invisible relationship
between
all of the o2 molecules that you're
inhaling
and the photosynthesis happening from
phytoplankton and trees
invisible 20 000 times a day it's
happening but it's happening
and that to have that level of
perception
is absolutely game-changing so it's an
augmentation and perception it's an
enlightening
it's more enlightening it's more holism
based
and it's it helps you when you do
unleash your gifts into the world it
helps you do it from a more
enlightened and aware perspective so
beautiful
i love that i love that
let's unpack make plus you started
giving us
a a run-through
of the pressure cooker
in a sense a forcing function for you
and i love that like the entrepreneurs
it's like knock knock knock you ready
you know and that like that happens kind
of
ties like answer the call you know
yeah right yeah um so i i kind of i
touched based on a lot of points here
um now i feel like i just want to
connect everything together to show you
how we got to make plus with an
architecture background
and clearly we've already established
that i like to make things
right um working here i had realized
that
um there's a lot of people who also want
to be able to make things right
and and making things is a very relative
term like you can
you can make uh like the cr concept of
creativity and what we
foster in terms of making is either
making
um like furniture and built objects or
it could be more of a virtual thing
where you're you're talking about
photography and videography or you're
talking about making music
or you're i mean the options are
unlimited right
the the journey of make plus started
with the vision
of a wood shop right that's that's what
i am i i wanted to sort of have a space
to
to build things and to to sort of put
you know my ideas
to life to bring them to life um and
then i
i kind of started putting the space
together and i had all this extra space
that i didn't really know
how to how to organize exactly but i
always thought to myself that
you know with there's this analogy of
build it and they will come
right and so it was always like let's
put it together let's build
my idea let's build my baby and bring it
to life right
and then see who finds themselves most
suitable
to to fit in to plug it into this big
machine right
and and there wasn't really a
pre-thought and that's probably why
there's such
different um modes of creativity or
outlets of creativity that we foster
at make plus it's because there was no
predetermined idea of what works
together
right there was a wood shop the wood
shop was making things
physical things right then somehow there
was a
a photography studio right and that was
just because
there were a couple of photographers
that i know of and then we're here in la
where
you know photography videography there's
a scene for that there was a demand for
that and so
we created that photography studio and
then
um i remember that uh or let me actually
just break it down first we have
make plus currently operates a wood shop
we have a photography studio
we have a digital fabrication studio and
i'll get into what that is
we also have a music studio and a set
production uh
studio right so all these things started
from there was a wood shop
yep right yep and then the wood shop
said if we had um
knock house who is the the music
production um
company that we have um came in at some
point and
it was this group of guys who were just
looking for a space
to build something right to build their
own studio and they came to me with this
idea of hey
we have this idea we want to put it
together we need you to we need some
consultancy services right we need your
your help building all this stuff
because we have
what it takes to you know make the
studio work but we need the space
itself um and i remember them coming
into the shop to discuss this and then
seeing the space and i remember us
walking through it together
and then it just hit me like why can't
it be here
you know like why can't this be the
space that you guys
are doing your music stuff where we can
co-link
the music with the photography right and
then by doing that we started having
some of their clients who came in
and started wanting us to build props
for them for music videos for things
like
that and somehow this harmony started to
develop and then the props we were
putting together were more
on the physical stand of things right
but then there was more of like a
design sort of set production situation
that was required for most of the videos
that we were trying to shoot and things
like that
and that's where um our other sister
company drip dome
came in right which is also part of make
plus
and that's that's how they fill in that
gap and now we have this like
gigantic intertwined community of all
these different creative outlets that we
provide
to people but also have people come to
us and say
hey well we want like this holistic
package right
we want this whole thing where we can
start from
recording a song to shooting the music
video and making the props required for
that music video
and we're that one stop shop that lets
you have all of that
right we actually have some
different images of some of the stuff
that we put together for these sets and
these props that
we can pull up do you guys get this
i just wanna i just wanna make sure that
people get it
because first of all omar
takes the knock knock knock and he
sees that this is the call this is the
call to adventure this is the risk
high risk high reward this is
sovereignty
right be your own supreme
authority and lead from that creativity
and so
so in taking this it's very risky you
know there's a big
there's a big lease on it's a big
warehouse
and there's a big lease and this is it
was signed for five
years mm-hmm and that's a big deal
people are
scared to sign a year further for their
house is a scary one
what five virgies yeah and so you know
so this is a big deal this is a huge
it's a huge thing but to have the
the trust to have the faith to take the
leap
and to know that i will
make it happen i will wake up every day
with a fire so bright under my ass
ikigai it's going to roar
me up and it's going to roar me to
create and
we have to also create from that most
morally ethically and spiritually
advanced and awakened place so that
everything we touch is gold
and as we do that process the pieces
fall
into place people talk about this all
the time whatever percent people say
it's 90
whatever it's just showing up meaning
you wake up every day
and you get to find the people that
are going to be coming to pass along
some of the technology and massive
equipment
that is super needed to have the first
makers coming into the space to have
these partners coming into the space
to have to know that you know that
meeting is set up with
with knock house and you know
i mean these they did you guys you guys
did
such such a good job yeah this is i mean
this is just you guys
you guys here is a whole
oh oh my my sorry guys my uh
my ndi connection is uh didn't catch
that but
they're then uh we'll pull it up but
yeah knock house la
you know on instagram
then we'll have potentially oh omar's oh
he has an image up perfect
okay so uh
so you know you know they did they did a
really good job at putting this together
i'll let you
unpack this i i want to say i want to
say
one more thing one more thing before we
get here and then we'll unpack that
because look at that i mean that's just
like
so gorgeous the thing that i want to say
is that
omar also you know he
recognized that it's not a wood shop
only
right there's a synthesis there's a
synergy component to this
where the truly remarkable ideas
emerge when you have the wood shop
but then when you take this leap into
music production
let's bring music production into the
warehouse where the wood shop is
let's see what synthesis emerges let's
bring these
what is what would you say drip domes is
that what is that called the the strip
dome was a set production
set production so then set production
makes more sense
but it's still also another another leap
i mean these are
this is the type of stuff you have to
you have to think
that you know wood and wood fab space
and wood are also somewhat different
that you're gonna some people are gonna
wanna
do work on on metals and glass and all
this other kind of stuff that's
different than wood
so again it's just that synthetic
perspective of synthesis
and taking that leap so to me it's
gorgeous that
that that's sort of the path that really
opened up the doors and it wasn't just
restricted to the wood shop
right but it's that future of synthesis
where all of these great
things are going to emerge from that
from these diverse minds in the same
place
i actually have something really
important that i want to point out that
i remember
this is something that i used to say a
lot at a very
early stage of when i was putting all of
this together
i think that it's very important
to know your people and build your team
right
one of my biggest concerns was putting
the right people together to drive this
force i
am a firm believer that there is no way
that one person
can drive a force so powerful or
to become so powerful right by
themselves i i completely believe that
you need
several people that are all pulling this
whole thing together and and the bigger
it gets the more people you need and i
think that the biggest struggle
is finding the right people yeah right
yes and it's very important for me to
bring out
that yeah we we've mentioned omar omar
omar a few times but that's that's kind
of making me a little self-conscious and
it feels
i'm being a little selfish here it's not
omar you know
there's there's like more than 10 to 15
people that are very very crucial into
the bringing
of what it what make plus is right now
right there are people who played a big
role in the setup portion there are
people who played a big role in the
operational portion there are people who
did the same
in um the making of like the classes the
small little pieces that bring the whole
thing together
right it's very important to acknowledge
that this is a team effort
and that that the team is what leaves it
you know to survive and i don't think
that in any way
that i could have got this to where it
is without the people that i have on
deck right likewise
um yes so i i have to say i'm very
appreciative to everyone who
was out there to make this come to life
and i am
like stoked for what the future of make
plus is
there was a time where i was like on a
very different spectrum i was just
very confused i didn't know if this was
actually working or not but the
validation that i got
from having other people support some of
the weight and and push things forward
with me
was just incredible yes
all right let's do it let's people you
got to know your people you know
you got to know your people it's
critical yeah but and it usually files
in from the leap of faith and the fire
under your ass because nobody no the
people right people aren't gonna
aren't gonna come when you're
half-assing right and that's very true
and and if
if if i wasn't at a point where i could
show someone something
for them to believe in it oh yeah like i
think that that was i mean i used to
talk about make plus
when it was just an idea and the
reactions i used to get versus
saying hey come to the shop let me tour
you yes you know and that's usually the
first thing i do
so people can get an understanding of
what is the space
you know what does it do what can i do
in this space yeah
um yeah hell yeah a lot of energy here i
love this is beautiful
physical manifestation come get a tour
of
the makespace of the studio of whatever
the entrepreneurs actually come look at
my code come look at my app come look at
my
my my biotech advancement you got to
show
you how to show move away from
entrepreneur to entrepreneur 100
yeah exactly yes okay beautiful
beautiful love that energy all right
all right we are going to unpack these
badass
images that we have and we'll also run
through a software
demo of of rhino to showcase uh how
the uh this set production is is being
done
so we'll do that all right so let's see
here let's get
up our our mixed effect
all right great so
so i'm gonna first start about i mean
start about start talking about some of
the things that we offer in terms of
like the fabrication services that we do
um should we show the space as the yeah
yeah
that could yeah we can do that it's the
thumbnail right now it's what you see in
the thumbnail
and it's also i believe
yeah that's the woodworking shop hell
yeah um
this is just one of the bays that we
have that basically this is this is the
woodworking trap
it's a fully equipped shop with all the
tools that you may need
um a lot of people also bring in some of
their hand tools and work on you know
their own stuff with that
but we also offer all of that um here's
some other photos
so good the tools that we have um and
then we can actually go back to
there's that bigger image there it is so
that's
that's basically the shot that we have
and as you can see instead of towards
the back i can point
here yeah um so these bays are what we
usually and that's this is kind of where
i'm about to get into like our business
model and how we operate
um one of the biggest problems coming
into what make plus
is meant to serve or the problem that
make pluses is meant to like sort of
cater to in terms of fabrication
services
is that um the maker spaces that are out
there
currently offer more of a membership
situation where you fee you find
yourself paying
for a bundle of hours or a bundle of
time when a lot of people actually do
this
on the side you know and so it's almost
like you're getting a gym membership but
you're only going to the gym once a
month right or maybe
maybe twice a month and so paying a lump
sum of money
is is a commitment that people don't
want to do and i kind of found this like
um this sort of business
loophole that we can probably work out
which was inspired a lot by
the scooters that we have out there
where you know you scan the thing
and then it starts charging you for the
time you use it and my biggest question
was
well why can't we just have the same
concept but for woodworking
like why can't we be this space that
people can come in
um scan something log the amount of time
that they use that
machine or that space and just walk out
and have to pay for just what they did
right and so we devised several
different models that cater to the
specificity of what you were trying to
do
right so we have a pay-per-minute model
where you get a small workspace and
that's completely free but that's for
much smaller objects that you need to
work on and we only charge you for the
time that you actually use the tools at
the shop
um the other method of payment is for a
little
bigger scale where you need extended
periods of time and and more
space to work on it we actually call
that more space
and that's what you see in the back
where you're actually
um can you pull that up real quick yes
um so these bays out here in the back
these are these are usually rented out
per day
um you get access to the space and the
tools um
and that way you are only paying for the
days that you're required to build that
project that you have to work on and
then you're out of there and then you
have no other commitment
but for those who actually want that
sense of commitment and know that this
is something that they want to do over
and over in time
then we also have residency programs
where you can be grandfathered into a
lot of
things at the shop where you get access
to the 3d printers the laser cutters
certain uh amounts of time with the
spaces and things like that so we kind
of
devised we're not trying to put out too
many options because that is kind of
confusing when you offer way too many
things we're trying to be as concise as
we can but as well
as cater to as many people as we can yes
in terms of offering what we can offer
right
so that's that's in terms of how we
operate the shop
now quick quick say um the idea of
looking at the scooters
and at all of the other sort of
technologies that are
becoming more and more a
democratized and be people able to just
use them for a couple minutes and as
needed without needing to buy the actual
equipment
it's a really really important insight
that you got
and that that you're bringing moving
forward a lot of people
want to just use a tool for a period of
time
and that's perfect and here's the thing
i think that
people are getting to a point where they
don't want to interact with people
to get to what they want to do you know
like people just want to streamline
actually one of the things that we had
initially thought about in terms of how
we operate this thing is that
we we kept saying streamline your
fabrication experience
right streamline it that was a big word
for us you know putting this whole thing
together
um and and the idea of having to go
through
one person to another through certain
levels of
you know orientations and things like
that and don't don't get me wrong like
you have to go through an orientation
for us to make sure that you know how to
use all the stuff
but we're just trying to make sure that
you are spending the least amount of
time you need
to spend in order to get access to what
you want and that's what people want
people now
are we're living at a at a point we're
in a world where people want that one
click
and boom i got it you know one click one
click one click
and so the less interaction people have
to go through to get to what they want
the better
less less friction is really really
important yes
and to make the
to not completely kick out
the human yet is also
important in the sense of our
specifically in a specific field i'll
say in
artificial intelligence is important to
keep the human in the loop for a while
and hybridize i mean you guys have a
hybrid as well obviously some like the
person comes in
and they don't know where the tool is
that they're trying to rent
i mean they're gonna have to talk to
somebody i mean so it's
the ai human hybrid is the is for now i
mean
you'll you'll be getting into within 10
years you'll be getting into autonomous
cars so
um there's not going to be a human in
those so um
you'll uh there's there's going to be
this gentle transition into what we're
what we're talking about and you we're
already
there on grocery stores obviously
self-checkout i mean
i when i when i when i have to uh you
know buy 10
10 of something i don't scan it 10 times
i ask the person will you please come
and mark it times 10 because i can't do
that
so it's still human ai hybrid in many
ways so
um but this is it's friction friction
and molasses are the things to get out
of the way
so that we can more effectively create i
can log in
you know down soon you guys will have
this ability as well
um is that you know if i want to
woodwork at 2 a.m
right i'm just logging into the app
right walking through the door
doing my woodworking from two to four
when nobody else is in there
how much do we love that i love that i
love doing stuff when nobody else is
doing stuff
yeah yeah 100 that's when you're like
most zoned into your own thoughts and
you don't have any of those distractions
um i i so in terms of
the making the space autonomous we
we are doing our best in terms of like
trying to create that
lack of friction that you were talking
about right so when you actually book a
space
right on the website you will go through
a series of questions
that ask you what tools you need and
what things you need and
and then by the time you're ready for
your reservation you come and the space
that we're offering
already has all the little hand tools
that you need and you already have
access to all the big tools
so in essence it is an autonomous
process
the part that we can't eliminate is we
have to make sure that people can do
this safely
yes so there has to be a point at which
someone is there to like walk you
through the process
show you our rules and then sort of
guide you make sure that you know how to
use these machines so you're not going
to hurt yourself
right because at the end of the day
there's a disclaimer on
there yes definitely definitely yeah
yeah
um yeah this is the kind of stuff yeah
yeah
the lawyers the lawyers urged
zack
but i mean you're right friction needs
to be eliminated as much as possible
because people want to just be able to
that's why things like amazon have the
buy now with one click
one right there you're trying to
simplify how fast you can get what you
want
yeah and that's what we're trying to do
the i like i love your vision with the
autonomous fab space yeah it's great
it's beautiful i mean we we also yeah i
mean ideally
like i said we're basing our model off
of the scooter so it's it's pretty much
the same we we have an
app that you know you have to download
and then that's how you access the space
um we're at a point right now where
we're finalizing the last kinks of
how to actually operate these things and
the app will hopefully be running
early january of next year yes um but
that being said i think the app is is
one thing that completely sets us apart
from any other makerspace that's out
there
you know just this idea of maybe we
haven't completely figured it out
but we're trying and i think it's gonna
work yeah you know what i mean
yeah just come just uh you know yeah you
need the
you need the screwdriver you you need
the power you powered power drill you
need the
the cnc you need the 3d printer for a
bit
um and there's a lot there's a lot
there's a lot you just check mark off
those for
60 minutes each and then you walk in and
you're already checked out via card
pretty much and this is you're just
you're in there you're doing your thing
you're building for a day or two
nobody's going to bother you besides
me popping up and saying hey is
everything okay
but that's pretty much it you know and
then you're out of there and you have
what you
wanted to build then you brought your
idea to life
yes that's it okay excellent and i love
that philosophy which we'll get to also
um as we we unpack because uh
it's really important for people to make
their ideas come to life that's
that's one of the big fundamentals of
the nature of reality
yes so we have this is that was the
biggest uh
shot of the the widest angle shot
i can also go ahead and show some of the
other spaces in terms of like this
is our photography studio um we call it
the photography studio but it's also
a multi-functional room that can be
rented out for several different kinds
of events we've had
art exhibitions we've had people dancing
in there you know it's just a big
open raw space for people to just go
crazy in
you know and then it obviously can be
set up as a photography studio it comes
with a couple backdrops etc
um and then these are the little bays
that we were talking about downstairs
and so that's how you see it's a 10 by
15 area and then
per year reservation when you first you
know submit everything
on the website we'll know what tools you
need and by the time you come in they're
all set up on this rack
and you just come in and start working
on your thing and all you've got to
bring with you is your materials
and then these are some of the photos
actually this is one of the photos where
you see the photography studio being
used for an exhibition
cool um and finally we also have
the which we already brought up a couple
times but that's uh one of the music
rooms that we offer
um knock house is the company that
actually runs the music studio so this
is one of their rooms
um we actually built this room from
scratch so awesome that room
did not exist at all i actually should
have probably put up some of the uh
before and after photographs that we had
um oh yeah but we could probably
pull them up oh yeah yeah cool cool
let's uh let's go
let's go pluck those quick go for it um
on ig and yeah
that's ralph right there one of the guys
ralph
um and let's see if we can find
where the was there is it was in this
one
i believe they might have a photo posted
somewhere with a video of what it used
to be
um but yeah it was it was a it was a
really oh this one i think right
you know maybe there you go that's
that's a video i don't know if it's a
video that shows you
the before no this probably this is one
of the afters
um it's okay point is
none of that stuff existed yeah you know
it was a completely
gigantic empty space um and these guys
came in they said we wanted to put a
room together
right like that's what we wanted to do
and we wanted to put together a music
studio and there was
obviously a lot of problems in terms of
like we have
a fabrication space those those spaces
are loud
you know and a music studio is a room
that needs to be completely silent
that's right and so that was a big
struggle for us in terms of like
really and you know all about how like
you know for
things like this it needs to be quiet
yes right yes
um and so it was it was a it was a
struggle it was a fun experience we
learned a lot
we made a few mistakes but for sure we
definitely got it to a point where
it's working it's working really well
and i feel like
you know everyone is happy with the
outcome
and everyone is at a point where they
have manifested their ideas to reality
and now they just want to move this
forward
right yep um yeah that that photo right
there
so this is one this is one of two
rooms right and then this is the other
room um this one actually comes equipped
with
a sound booth
or a mic booth and a bathroom it usually
gets booked out for like 24 hours
straight because people feel really
comfortable in it which is something
that doesn't normally exist in music
studios
you know they're usually in like you'll
find the rooms and then there's a big
hallway it's a corporate building and
then the bathrooms are down the hall
this is more of like people literally go
in there for over eight to ten hours
yeah they don't even come out
yeah which is great um wow and
again we kind of created zone yeah yeah
we kind of also touched based on this
idea of
um how the music studio has begun to
bring us a lot of customers in terms of
like people who want to
shoot their music videos yeah so we
actually have like here's an image of
um someone shooting a music video it was
a quick dance rehearsal they were doing
and things like that
and then the um also the synthesis that
we've created with all these
uh pieces that we've put together um
gave us things like this and so this is
sort of
us moving into that small tutorial that
we were talking about we were
commissioned by
um drip dome and knock house which are
our
sister companies to create this for a
rapper
um who's actually also one of the owners
of
knock house and he
wanted he basically walked up to me and
said
i have a music video and i want to jump
out of my mouth
i took a second to like take that in
first and then i was like all right
let's make you a mouse you know and this
is this is actually
really big like you're talking it's it's
over 16 feet wide
and a little over 10 feet tall so that's
i mean it's it's large yes yes yes um
and and this
sort of came from a 3d model that we
initially put together
um let me go ahead and pull this closer
i love it let's do it
so this is what is rhino
rhino rhinoceros rhinoceros which is
would you call this cad um it's it's one
of the modeling softwares that are out
there
yeah um maya being another popular maya
being another popular one
yeah and there's there's some
substantial differences between the two
um but this one is is very easy in terms
of like
it's very user-friendly it's
command-based so most of the things that
you want to do
like all you got to do is just type line
and then boom you can draw a line and
there's that line right and so
because of that ease of use this is
one of the more preferred programs to
use um
but going back to what we did is we we
kind of got this image and we sort of
traced it out created um
what we called like guidelines for the
panels that it was cut
out of and then we sort of put together
a three-dimensional figure of
um how this whole thing comes together
and this was a quick mock-up of how we
believe that the structure needs to work
together
and then we moved on from this to
actually fabricating it
we see and seed most of the um the the
shapes out here and then we just cut up
the dimensional lumber and and fastened
it together to create the actual prop
um and this this entire process took
two days to bring this from from the
digital forum
to a reality two days two days it was
a day worth of modeling and then a
morning of cnc
and a night of putting together you know
wow
and obviously the painting and all that
stuff was a quick
process that's a that's a fast
turnaround for a
uh 10 foot by 16 foot 10 foot by 16 foot
yeah yeah that's
a that's a good one and a lot of people
have the idea but that
you know to actually get it executed
that's and this is interesting so you
can basically take in
uh this in so in
software you can both see
where you would cut out specifically uh
like so let's so what what are
you walking through the process yeah so
basically there are some things that are
just rules of thumb
that you know right like most sheets
that you can get are four by eights
right most of the mach most c and c
machines at least the ones that we have
and the ones that we like to use are all
um ones that fit four by eight beds
um and but what that means is that you
buy a four by eight sheet as it is and
you just put the entire thing on the bed
yeah
um it's a more expensive one because it
can do that
a lot of times you'll get the more
miniature versions of those things which
are like
uh you know a two foot by two foot bed
or things like that but
for a bigger fabrication you need a
bigger bed
for the material right right and so what
we essentially did here
is we first drafted out we
we traced the um and i'll go ahead and
hide some layers just to show you what
it all looks like
um but we basically
we got this image um and
we traced the image out so that's how
you see the lines
right yeah yeah um and then and this was
and we basically got the sheets
of four by eight right so this oh those
are those
oh and so we had to run three separate
four by eight sheets because
obviously the machine fits one sheet at
a time yeah
and then we cut out the left side we cut
out the middle side and we cut out the
right side
and then um we basically had the
structure put together
um and i can show you in uh what we call
shaded view
to separate layers and colors but that
pink stuff over here is the structure
yep and that was sort of you know
measured and modeled and sort of pre-cut
in terms of just dimensional two by
threes we built the structure together
and just basically fastened the lips to
the structure i love it and that's the
end and that's it yeah that's that
i i love the the three four by eights
and then how you had so that was in the
cnc
and then how then the cnc cut us it out
and then how
you guys put those together uh so what
did you use to put them together
we actually we centered we centered the
dimensional lumber on
the seam of where the piece and piece
goes
and so by doing that we just and that's
that's kind of sort of why
we have um like you can see them in the
image
um but we have like this this this is
exactly where that seam is
right and so these two panels are
fastened here and here yep
and these two panels are fastened here
and here and that's how the whole thing
comes together
um a cnc essentially by the way is a
machine
that carves out of wood right it
basically
can create contours it can cut out
dimensional depth into the object and
create like a three-dimensional
sort of feel to it it essentially
operates
by running a router bit which i can
probably zoom that in
but it runs a router bit it's basically
like a drill and the drill is
is upright and and there are some which
can actually go in
in different axes as well but for the
most part it
it runs upright and it just carves into
the wood and it can go
it can go sort of it can create these
little rivets that you see over here it
can also go all the way through and cut
the pieces out
so this is this is a our cnc operating
on a different
sort of uh project but it's it's
essentially the same idea right
where this bit is going around and
carving things out as it goes
yeah and so with the four by eight
sheets that you saw
here i this started off by
being like a full rectangular sheet and
basically the cnc just went in and cut
out these contours
this way all the way through and then we
just had to piece it all together yeah
wow yeah and then so the cnc also then
takes into account the
teeth this really sort of like more
difficult you know like you were showing
with that what looked like
you know that third dimension going in
and making these beautiful
you know that that's really so you guys
also painted it yeah i mean it
so the cnc is just a machine that does
a certain job which is it revolves a bit
and it moves around
a bed right and what we do on our end is
we first come up with the
actual object that we're trying to
create and then
um the program that the cnc
sort of uses to enable the cut or to
make the cut
understands and converts the the object
that you've created
the three-dimensional object you've
created into just numbers
right and so these numbers are basically
just coordinates and those coordinates
reference where that bit needs to go and
that's how it cuts the pieces out so if
your coordinates were to go from this
point to this point to this point to
this point to this point in an
arc like this it's just going to do that
right and that's how you end up with
that little
uh curved shape that you have yeah so it
breaks it down into the four by eight
yes and then a grid of coordinates yes
and then it goes and it precisely
follows your you know left side of the
mouth four by eight and all the
different coordinates for the mouth for
the lips and then for the teeth
and then uh yeah so you guys are just
lifting up
only the the lip and the teeth out of it
and then
the open gap to the mouth is left right
there as the piece of wood computer
numeric control
yeah that's what it is it's really a
brilliant
uh invention i love yeah cnc is can't
take credit for that but yeah it is a
great invention
we can planetarily yeah we i mean
we're using it yeah and it's it's
enabling a massive amount of creativity
yes
rhino rhino appears to be
really enabling for
you know just taking that idea i want to
jump out of a mouth boom
putting it in there and then sort of uh
i love the 3d space like
you know that's something that i don't
get much of in in sketch
you know um is i don't get that too much
but
uh you know in here you really get it
and then it's interesting like you bolt
on that support
and then rhino knows if that's going to
uh
successfully hold that up or if it's
gonna
no fail that at that point i mean there
are plug-ins that you can get
to rhino that can start doing structural
calculations and figure that thing
those those parts out for you um in this
case
i mean these are common pieces of wood
to work with these are this is a common
scale to work with and so
it's it's also common knowledge to
understand what will and will not work
um there are certain i mean it's pretty
much the the framing process is pretty
much like putting up a wall
right so if you know how to put up a
wall you can pretty much
structure any vertical element or
vertical plane wow right i guess i i
just
realized that that this could be a
really good
um
that that's i think a super good idea
for um for the
for the for the portals like
for like this for like that would be a
really interesting idea if
you know like we're talking about
homeboy jumping through the mouth
like it would be a good idea to make a
portal
and then have people jump through the
portal
into a higher level of perception um
that's what make plus is here for
we're there for you we can create that
portal for you
that's such a good idea i don't know if
people will actually jump into a high
level of
perception after jumping through the
portal but maybe
what we do is we put the um
we put the you know this would require a
little bit more work but
if we put the the orange side of the
portal
uh on the same piece of like four by
eight as the
blue side of the portal but on the other
side of it and then
we um we had the orange room
be something that was a lower level of
perception
and then they like ran through jumped
through into the blue room and it was a
higher level
of nuance and perception you could use
like fabrics and things like that so
you're actually jumping through the
fabric and you'll have like an orange
screen on one side and a blue screen
i love that the little i know you would
i know you would
i know that's great oh this is good
stuff
that because yeah that basically turns
into this that that turns into this guy
here like
maybe you can kind of uh maybe you can
basically put
just like a tree with a very little bit
of nuance on the orange side
and then put the tree with the
significant amount of nuance on the blue
side
and then just have people just run right
in and jump through
people love interacting with things man
people love
love that kind of stuff that could be a
really fun interactive high level
perception
exhibit 100 percent and you have and you
have drip dome now which basically
you know you guys you guys made this uh
in uh uh halloween right right yeah we
had we had a halloween
event recently and this swing was
gorgeous it was uh
it was really well supported and it
enabled people to swing on it and it
also was decorated gorgeously with roses
and flowers and
and so you know dripdome and you guys
that make plus did a
really really solid job with this and
people love this
yeah they they did an outstanding job
decorating it that's
that's a complete fact um the structure
was pretty good too it held itself there
were a couple of doubts at first but
when we had a couple of tests
on it and we put some substantial weight
on the swing we all got
really relieved that it could do what it
could do but yeah this was an
interesting project that we worked on
and this this basically opens up a
gateway for a lot of the things that we
can do together
um because and even that mouth like a
lot of the the painting came from them
instead of the
picking out you know how the mouth needs
to be the size all that kind of stuff
even when we actually shot the video for
that um
they put together the entire set for
that video so
i mean they fill
a gap in make plus and so does knock
house and i feel like the harmony that
we
that we have excuse me is is incredible
like we we work really well together we
bring each other a lot of clients we
bring each other a lot of work
um and we're just we're a great team
yeah those are some of the images from
the set
i i love in this one you can be you can
really start
you can really start seeing look up
there you can start seeing the
definition in the teeth
yeah that depth in the teeth which is
really cool yeah
i like that a lot that's that's super
unique and
i think these ideas coming to life in
the
in the physical things to make plus and
and and drip dome and and um basically
the
engine of like an autonomous fab space
like
i would love to in the future even
go like i would love to send you my
portals graphic and just kind of like
maybe
like just quick face time about it and
then maybe have you guys
figure out how to bring it to reality
reality and that's like uh whatever
two thousand dollar project or whatever
people pay for that this kind of
we'll figure the numbers out but that's
but that's really what it should be it
should be like a nicer higher level
higher quality or maybe you have those
levels like you we can make it for 400
super cheap you know 1500 medium level 4
000 like
dude people's minds are going to be
blown type thing and that could be
what um people can do in the future is
maybe there's like a submissions like an
art submissions that way
it's also kind of uh a little bit more
decentralized and crowdsourced
crowdsourcing is one of the best ways to
elicit high-level innovation that
especially that other people are
aren't thinking of and so that could be
quite interesting for make plus
and drip dome is maybe there's maybe we
do a you know this could be something
good that we do together
with with our simulation community and
also our
our uh community that we're aiming to
establish with rich patrons as well
maybe we put one of the 10 000 or 20 000
um patronages from the um from the rich
patrons community and we put that
into a a crowdsourcing project with the
make plus strip dome team
and we basically say okay the coolest
submission
from our collective community into this
will get you know you know two like two
ten thousand dollar projects or four or
five thousand dollar projects will
get made through this and we'll put
those four up and do a brand new exhibit
and stuff like that
yeah we have so many great things to do
like this and the crowd sourcing
part is awesome and then maybe we can
fly the four artists
into la to be there that made those
submissions and they can be a part of
the fab process
which would be super dope so i mean
i love this type of stuff the creativity
is roaring and
it's just like it's just kind of what we
need also in terms of creativity and
community is the other thing like this
this is
really really solid and i'm i love how
you also brought forth
um just when you give us that
it on a demo level i think it it sits
in on the how especially if somebody
doesn't know
that i can download rhino and i can
begin playing around this i can watch
some stuff on
youtube khan academy ck12 foundation
there's so many different places it's
actually a really easy program to use
you know like
it's it's a great way for you to be able
to to
think of this this form and then start
testing out different
models and like different um iterations
of
what that idea really means visually
without having to invest
any like money into actually building
and creating models and things like that
and like without having to experiment
just
right on on hand on the on the actual
thing right
it's a good way to just ha find that
small buffer between
okay it's in my head and it's real
there's a there's a small ground in
which you're you're manifesting that
idea and that this is a
beautiful platform for you to be able to
do that
um yeah yeah so
let's see here um we got to unpack
most everything i think we get i think
there's probably another small thing
that we should say which is that
um that sort of bit about
the the diagram of how people funnel in
the
tree diagram and then how everyone is a
maker and that how people leave with a
piece of
that they've made and then that how
that's super inspirational
to them to get them started especially
everyone is a maker
but the term maker is a very relative
term right um
in in terms of everyone has the ability
to create something and to project their
ideas
it's it's being able to provide the
medium
for that person to actually be able to
create that thing is the difficult part
right
and and i think make pluses is actually
broken down into the tree that you were
talking about it's
it's a it's sort of a filtering process
that's that helps people who come to
make plus
understand where they need to start so
you got to think about it like it's
almost like a game
right you start and it's asking you a
bunch of questions to identify
where to place you but essentially the
final end game
is that you get to a point where you can
create
on your own time at your own pace
comfortably however you want
right so um and this is also portrayed
in the website so as soon as you land on
the website the first question you get
um is start your maker journey or start
your journey here right and as soon as
as soon as you hit that we can actually
go through the process together
yeah okay all right so let's go through
we got
uh uh if you if you go on yours i can do
your head
i can do your head yeah let's do that i
can do your head at the same time yeah
and you can control it because yeah you
know you're all right so
let me get rid of these and get rid of
this all right boom
there we go so this is this is where
this is the first thing you see when you
land on the website
make plus dot u s everywhere plus dot u
s um it gives you a quick preview of the
space but this is
more of the industrial space and then if
you scroll a little down
you'll see some of the uh different
spaces that we offer in terms of the
photography studio et cetera et cetera
but notice how the first question is
start your maker journey and that's kind
of where
like we break down and filter you into
where you need to be to continue and to
get to where you want to go yep
um so you hit start your make journey
and then it asks you if you have prior
experience or not and i think that's a
very crucial question
in terms of it is i personally don't
have that much experience using power
tools and i would love to go through a
bunch of learning lessons
exactly and that's where the no button
takes you so
it'll take you to a page where you can
start to sign up for all these different
courses that we offer some of them are
micro courses for those of you who have
less time to spend some of them are
actually introductory courses where
it's a two day workshop where you
actually get to learn
the entire process we have workshops for
woodworking metalworking and even
welding so
it really depends on what path you're
trying to
to take or what you're trying to make
but after you cross
the path in terms of like getting
getting the knowledge that you need to
actually use the tools
that's when we go back um and then we go
through the yes
answer to that question and that's where
you actually get all these different
ways that we talked about in terms of
being able to access the space
so your options are to either pay per
minute and you have a one day project
you want to cut up a couple of things
boom learn more download the app come to
the shop
boom second is i i need more space
more time um and then you hit that
and then it shows you a quick brief of
like these are the different spaces we
offer
um it shows you this is again the space
is completely emptied out
the access to the tools that you get how
you can lay out your stuff and be
comfortable and working you can book
more than one space at a time depending
on the size of your project
and so forth um and so really the the
main
the main reason for the filtering
process is to is to also go back to that
idea of
of the um of being autonomous right
in terms of like minimizing how much you
need to go through before you
you speak to somebody you know that you
can filter yourself find yourself in
that category find all the information
you need
everything you know just by being at
home and then just showing up for your
reservation
when you're ready for it or just to
showing up for your class when you're
ready for it you know what i mean
yeah um and so the tree basically
funnels people out
um in order to get you to a point where
you can fundamentally in the end
bring your ideas to life yeah
i i wa you know log just jump on
you know i have an idea i want it to
come to life then i get funneled into
you know do i know power tools do i not
know power tools
okay i don't what courses do i need to
take okay i see i get some human
intervention i get some training some
tools
and then i get on the autonomous side
right and then and then
my ideas come to life at my own pace and
rate so it's like
it's like training wheels in a sense
pretty much pretty much it's beautiful
and and if you if you didn't want to go
through the process of making it if you
were not
interested in learning how to make
things but you wanted something made
anyway
um that's where you hit our little
services tab
ah okay all right so one moment so okay
so there at the top is the services tab
right
and that's where so that our services
tab is like all the way at the top in
that little menu that we have
and then this is where it says hey do
you need something made but you don't
have the tools or experience
we can do it for you we can do it right
yep and you can pick out whether
you want us to see and see something
because you don't have one or laser cut
something for you
because you don't have a laser cutter or
if you want us to just build something
completely from scratch which is what
we're talking about with the portals
which is
exactly yeah exactly high level
perception
versus low level perception type stuff
yeah if you guys want to make sense
so this is the important one especially
in la with the entertainment industry
for those local
and even in you know norcal's not too
far away and san diego was not either
but the idea is that this is especially
common right now in
la for set design for
music videos this type of stuff people
really like it for that
and you can get the whole process done
you know like you can have
you can record your music then build
in the photography studio and then
exactly you know and
the music studio is where you make it
yeah you know
then you can record your music video you
can have us create the props for it etc
etc
yeah you can produce a whole music video
with creative props that make plus yeah
boom it's a one-stop shop it's a
one-stop shop that's
uh that's a vertical integration my
friend that's what it is that's what it
is yeah that's what it is remember i
told you about the teams you know yeah
you gotta have the right people for the
right things
you gotta have your people you know yeah
this is so exciting i think so much
creativity unleashed yeah i
i love talking about this stuff it also
gives me a uh
a second to like sit back and reflect
that's right
that's right yeah and you start
criticizing yourself and the things you
say and the way you portray it and you
you also
it's almost like you're at this point
where you're
being interviewed but you're also your
own audience at
some point totally on you're listening
to how you're talking about this right
and then you're learning more by the way
that you're talking about it yes
i i i'm very grateful that you chose to
have me on the show
yeah thank you for that i i gave you the
analogy earlier it is a
unique essence of a flower that we are
smelling uh from every single one
yeah it's just a it's a blossoming
flower and we're like
you know this is omar earlier was
jeanette you know this is the style of
like
oh that's their soul essence like i love
it i'm i'm drinking it up
i'm smelling it up i'm eating it up i'm
tasting it and it's
it is really nice and it's inspirational
because it's very entrepreneurial it's
very artistic
um it's very driven in by actualizing
other people's gifts which is
ultimately that is such a deep future
trend is that service to other
and that is where all of these fruits
come to us is when we're
serving us ourselves and the world
simultaneously
um so
yeah and that process happens to
a lot of us is where we have the sort of
like you know we hear so much take a
moment to smell the roses right
take a moment to reflect on how far
you've come
because the a lot of the times the the
entrepreneur can
be hardcore you know north star focus
which is great but
it's super important to also ground that
in the you know that present moment
that that deep awareness and presence
that then
enables you to really
recognize how tremendously profound it's
been like damn just you know two years
ago or a year ago or six months ago or
three months ago and
like look at where you're at now be
grateful gratitude gratitude gratitude
times infinity
every moment and then that will like
just that's one of the most powerful
driving forces itself and yeah in
yeah there's yeah i want to ask you some
stuff about vision
also because i mean you've given us a
tremendous amount already
but something that i think is um
really powerful at make plus that
i don't really get to see too much at
other places um
is that the fab space itself is very
synthetic it's synthesis driven across
different disciplines
and i think that there's there's
something about
basically like you know okay so let's
say we
put up a put up a warehouse and then you
throw a bunch of
you know different likes even like
slightly different fields like if you
threw a couple
you know biologists and computer
scientists and neuroscientists in
you're going to get like computational
neuroscience and computational biology
and
stuff like that and and you know that's
kind of how places like
you know george church's lab over at
harvard um
as we interviewed him that he really
mentions that that's really one of the
core essences to how they've
succeeded and why they're one of the
most prolific labs on the planet
it's i think this very similar analogy
with
make plus is that the more that you put
the
the the woodworking with the fab
of cnc's and 3d printers and then you
throw in
the music production and you throw in
photography and video
and you throw in all this set design i
mean
you're inevitably going to get really
cool fruits that come from that
and then if you can sort of you know we
talked about this a little bit off
camera
is there is there a you know is there
make plus
la and then make plus san francisco
and and over in the bay area you know do
you keep the recording studio and do you
keep the set design
and the fab space is that potentially
something that could unlock more
creativity in the bay area like that or
do you want to try a different
combinatoric
a different combination should you try
to see what it's like if you throw um
a little bit of a you know a wet lab
like a biology wet lab in there at the
same time maybe people can start doing a
fab
space with a biology wet lab and see
what emerges from that
i mean the yeah the code of life mixed
with fab
is that's that's bioengineering yeah i i
mean i'm not opposed
well okay let's let's backtrack a little
bit so again
make plus the essence of make plus is to
i said this so many times already but i
think it's important to fixate on what
like
matters the most is the essence of make
plus is to bring your ideas to life
what that means is up to
where mate plus is right make plus
happen to be in la
that's where it started because that's
where i was and
the force attracted like-minded
individuals and put together the music
studio the photography studio and the
set production
right i see two different
potentials of how this can grow first
i would love for make plus the current
make plus to just
you know foster itself and manifest
itself and just grow into this
space that has a lot of people at once
at any given moment
just outletting so many different modes
of creativity
in fabrication in the photography studio
the music studio things blasting left
things blasting right
that's what we want yeah but with that
being said we know that the harmony
of the music studio and the shop and the
photographies we know this works we
didn't at first
but now we do right it doesn't exist
somewhere else but now it does and it
works
and that's great but if we were to move
it
the one the one step would be to
actually move the entire
thing and have a new offspring make plus
again with knockhouse and with dripdome
and just
blow it up somewhere else and somewhere
else and somewhere else and the other
idea is that make plus becomes
this mobile umbrella of create like
fostering creativity
so the umbrella goes away we get another
warehouse somewhere else
we do whatever we did here that we know
works and start
outfitting that space with what is
required in that community
yeah that's right that's what i'm saying
in oakland on the east bay
berkeley bio labs i mean i'm telling you
that
area they have already i mean they
already have a really nice
kind of like cool spot out there and
there could be a fit for
a fab space um in there i mean there's
so much good stuff because
that you're right that in that specific
location there is a sort of
gravitational pull of the cultural
essences that will populate it itself
yeah
there's also another reason that make
plus works
well in terms of its fabrication side in
the place that it
is right now which is in downtown los
angeles is because a lot of people are
living in apartments
right and one of the things we like to
say is where the where the garage
that everybody wants to have at home
right but when you're living in an
apartment and you don't have that garage
you have made plus right so i think
as a force that attracts creatives
and creates a community that feeds off
of itself
make plus needs to continue to exist
here and hopefully will exist in several
different places
yeah um if it is what it is and it moves
as a whole as it is right now
great and if it moves to a different
spot which wants to attract
a different level of creativity and
different people then so be it
yeah yeah roger that yeah let's you know
yeah there's so many entrepreneurs that
that talk about this is that you know
really get the first train rolling
right steam and just
chugging along and then you're and then
it's like all right now
what do we do on the second train how do
we systematize that yeah i'm
100 on board let's let's crush make plus
and simulation we have a lot of
interesting collabs
um proud of proud of
knock house and drip dome as well very
proud of them
because uh they took the big risk with
working with you on on that they did
yeah yeah they did
yeah that's that's huge it's huge
do we feel like uh we got through enough
of uh the
make plus and the makers journey and the
photos we covered
are there more tabs and stuff at the top
that you think would be important to
cover
um in terms of some of the photos that i
have i feel like we covered
all the images and things like that i
just have more sort of operational
photographs
you know this is a shoot that we had at
make plus where we had a
green screen that was put out for an
animation video that was put together
um and then again there was some of the
dancing stuff that we saw
um and for the most part that pretty
much covers most of the images that i
had
more of not plus and things like that
excellent excellent and then uh
web is there something else on the web
at the tabs on the top what or you want
to just walk us through what those are
yeah i can walk you guys through i mean
we went through the maker journey
which shows you essentially like the
three modes that we offer in terms of
being able to make
um the per minute the per day
and then the per month right so that
breaks it down to how
committed do you want to be to the
active making right
um and then besides that we have another
tab that shows you
um your services and so that goes
through cnc
milling laser cutting and the custom
fabrication which we already covered
in terms of our media spaces i did show
the
photography studio but we also have a
couple of other spaces that we lease out
in terms of
creative spaces so one of them would be
this uh conference area where we have a
projector that projects on this big wall
and it's more of like a working s like a
working area right people
usually we bring in uh there's a big
conference table that we can bring out
and people have
meetings over there and things like that
yep um
sound is kind of a an issue though you
know and it's because there's there's
and so
we're we're very selective about like
yeah who actually uses the space and
whatnot
um and besides that we also have a store
where we sell some of our
little made objects by make plus and
make places this is
cool wait this is cool this is cool so
basically
you you're also turning it into the
artists actually being able
to get compensated for i love this this
is great for their creating yeah
yeah i mean this the idea of the store
actually came out very recently
um and we started putting together some
of the pieces that were made
either by uh myself or other people at
the shop or even commissioned by other
people with their consent to resell
yeah um and so we started putting
together some of these things
that we can sell out and then if you're
an artist and you want to actually sell
your stuff then that's something we can
also do if you just want to exhibit
that's something we also do because we
we
hold exhibitions we haven't done that
now because of the whole covid situation
but in general we also are a space where
we try to promote artists and we try to
you know
be that space that people want to gather
and see all the stuff that's
being made here and exhibited here
which takes me back to something that i
probably should have mentioned a long
time ago
but our four pillars have made plus like
the four things that we started by
saying
this is what make plus is um where make
teach collaborate and exhibit right like
those are our main four pillars
in every definition of what make is um
teach
in every definition of what teach be it
we teach you know the students or the
someone else comes and has a certain
level of expertise and wants to teach
that's something we also cater to and
foster
collaborate with all those different you
know points and and
pieces of the puzzle that we let you put
together and we have put together
and finally the um exhibit which is
being that platform that people can come
and sort of
see other creatives doing their thing
yep yep
that's the exhibit comes on both
hosting the live events and then also
the sales here that's
yup love it
i i think this the storefront the
storefront idea is so damn good yeah i
love the storefront idea yeah yeah
it's it's getting filled up it'll
probably fill up pretty soon we just
have to document a lot of the stuff that
we've made but
yes yes yeah i love that probably mostly
because of the sovereignty of the artist
yeah that's really the big thing yeah
you get to express yourself you know you
get to
have a voice i guess people are always
looking for
like oh by the way this is a one of one
you're
always looking for that yeah it's a 101
or you know one of four or whatever it
is but it's still hella cool to
um to also say that yeah i support a
local artist in la
you know people always love that too
that's yeah that's that's a hundred
percent true
and this is the platform for you to
share your stuff yeah instead of be that
artist that's being supported
i like the idea of make plus coming in
hot on the
you know that that
super unique uh furniture
store front ankle and uh
you know it could be cool like support
uh los angeles entrepreneur
you know omar or evan or whoever
and and yeah that that's
yeah that's great yeah yeah these are
these are just some of the images
of like the pieces that were put
together for this
um there's a breadboard this is actually
something that we teach in a class so
you could either buy it or you could
come learn how to make it and walk out
with it yeah yeah that's great yeah and
it's pretty much the same with some of
the other ones as well
um this whoops that table that you saw
right there
was actually commissioned by um
knock house so this is this is the table
that we're selling um but if you go back
to the images that i was showing you
there's that table right there oh yeah
there it is yeah i mean it's a little
skewed because of the panorama but
that's it right there
um and so really you could either
buy it or you can come learn how to make
it yeah and walk out with it yeah yeah
yeah that's so cool yeah and the
teachers are you
and then there's a couple others right
now yeah that are helping
that's awesome yep and then
that person becomes a teacher themselves
after they come and learn dude that's
how it happens
i mean it's that we had we have a a
student who at some point ended up
giving a couple of classes at make plus
you know and they started just by being
an enthusiast who wanted to learn how to
do all of this stuff
um and then took a few classes with us
really got and and i think that there's
a there's a certain
amount of um like when you really want
to do something
and then you also find yourself in the
space that lets you do that thing
you're going to do it really well yeah
you know and and that person really
wanted to learn
really wanted to be able to put things
together um and
and they've they'd learned and they put
a lot of things together and they said
hey i want to teach people how to do
this yeah
and that's again like everything
happened inside make plus the learning
the teaching
exhibiting etc etc yeah yeah
you running out of questions the mentor
passing along the knowledge of
teaching how to fish and then the
student themselves
becoming the mentor and teaching the
next student how to fish
is a big essence of life and
civilization and
so i love it i love that cycle and
you know ronnie vagus was a big
influence in
my director producer host abilities and
you know i i would i would say that
you're passed along
a good amount of your you know
fab space and and teaching process
to woodworking to
several teachers several students that
are you know going to become
hopefully teachers as well and maybe i
will too
in uh who knows how how long and
this is very much a massive
actually psychologists have have
specifically studied the phenomenon of
what
um makes people that are successful in
business
very happy and it's mentoring people
mentoring people that are younger
that are coming up in a similar career
path
man do they get happiness from from
passing along the wisdom
i believe you learn more by teaching
yeah that's what you do that's 100
100 100 yeah i just did this i just
streamed
uh one of my evernote distillations of
the california water system and
it was really fun because it totally is
that you do you learn more from teaching
you're basically forced it's a
compression
forcing function for you to
distill the teaching into a short
short period of time the main five
things that you have to pass along
you have to have emotional intelligence
to and you have to analyze the pattern
of where the person's at in there
tailor the teaching to that there's so
much that goes on in that
that's very true yeah and and in going
through
all of that you're strengthening your
knowledge of what you're doing precisely
yes now
all right we can rap make plus i want to
ask you a couple
questions
what would you say is the nature of
consciousness
um one good answer to that
in my opinion would be it's being able
to recognize
that you are aware of what you are doing
where you are going and where you are
and what led you to be where you are
yes um so i think that
to be conscious is to be aware
of your path right you asked me about
the north star what it is that i look
you know what sort of drove all this
what sort of is coming in the future etc
to me being conscious is knowing
how did i get to where i am right what
are the
what are the factors that led me to get
to this point
and where am i going from where i am
and and what are all the factors that
impact
how i get there yeah um so being able to
understand that
appreciate the things that let you get
to where you are
and don't take things for granted that's
being conscious yeah in a nutshell for
me
yeah that deeply reminds me of the
the roots and fruits in the present
moment so you know where you came from
you know
who you are you know your trajectory
where you're going that north star that
process
and you have that you've anchored that
divinity that gratitude that
peace bliss love that those highest
principles
in your butterfly effect your artistry
that you're cascading outward
now would you also
give us some of your thoughts around
why you think reality exists
i mean i this is this
it's i mean there's the whole i think
therefore i am and i
am therefore i think we can talk about
this on and on
and on um the nature of reality like
we exist because we we
make an impact things we do have
an impact on other things causality i
think is a very important thing for me
we kind of touched base on this in in
the past
um but i do believe that you're a force
a force of energy and
and this energy that you have that you
are projecting out there on the world
is going to impact a bunch of other
things and then therefore
create more other things that are
happening and that force
is something you can physically see you
can touch you can
in it and it it shows itself in
different ways
but just like the idea of when you put
together furniture
the validation of it being a tangible
object that i can touch that i can see
makes it real for me makes me happy to
do what i'm doing
right and so saying like
the idea of reality i understand reality
and i see reality because
i see the things that i do and what they
do
and the things that other people do and
how those impact the world so there's a
tangible
and it doesn't have to be something
that's actually just tangible like it
could be
something that you experience you know
but there's
a force that's moving from you out there
you know and you're making a mark here
you're making a mark there someone else
is making a mark there you're working
with someone to make
mark all these things are realities to
me you know
that's what makes the world real yeah
because otherwise if
like even if you're just sitting at home
and and i don't know if home is the
right way
the right word or place but if you're
just sitting and doing nothing
then there's there's no reality there
you know there's just nothing
yeah sri aurobindo and the mother mira
alfasa
talked about the metaphysical truth
behind consciousness force
and the warmth behind what in sanskrit
is referenced to as
[ __ ] agni or chit tapas and
that's literally like consciousness fire
and consciousness force
and that seems to be a fundamental play
a fundamental role in the nature of
reality as well
where there is this
and the beauty i think is that
science is affirming
given things like quantum theory the
absolute necessity to have
observers and therefore
consciousness in fact being fundamental
and therefore also
conscious agents making decisions
that then impact other conscious agents
and their experiences
so this may in fact be our metaphysics
that we are consciousness exploring this
reality
and we may continue if the cyclic
cosmology is true
we may in fact continue to explore
more combinations of realities
do you do you have an opinion about
about this in
in chapter
10 of high level perception where we
have the
the infinity graphic the very
recursive graphic
this one where we have the acorn that
turns into the oak tree
that then drops more acorns that drop
into more oak trees just like
the parents birth a child that then
grows up and marries another person and
they have a baby
and then make more children just like
humans were secreted from this planet
and then
we created the technological capacities
that are enabling us to dive into
infinite designer realities
i don't have an opinion in terms of like
a different approach or a different
understanding
of how this works i can i completely
believe that
the the forces that we have are
just like you have represented in that
diagram where you have
the human the the parents who end up
bringing another person who then ends up
continuing
and then bringing another person and
continuing and i think that that
is one way of looking at it from a
biological perspective like that's
a cycle that exists and we we can't deny
that
the existence of it that's why we exist
right
but at the same time it's the same as
what we were talking the driving forces
of doing things in life
like you know consciousness creating
reality
in which realities then create other
realities
and other realities and i think that
both of those are completely in sync
right without the biological
manifestation of how
human beings are procreating and moving
forward
um you won't have the different
people and the different opinions and
the different forces of energy that we
were talking about that are offspring
and creating more and more and more
and so yes it's a cycle but it's almost
like it's it's it's an exponential cycle
if that even makes sense right so it's
like
you have a circle that feeds off a dot
in the middle and then i'm just
i'm seeing this as a diagram you know
but i want to draw it let's do it okay
beautiful yeah all right what
is your choice of color um
i'll do green boom i like the screen
right actually let's get the
actually let me do the make plus yellow
i like that the make plus yellow
will we be able to see it let's see
let's test
can you see yeah let's try a darker one
yeah let's try a darker one sorry we can
keep make plus yellow
on the page but yeah let's do i'll do a
black black oh that's the secondary
color
that's a secondary color um
so the way i see it is you have
the your basic understanding of a cycle
is something that
turns around and completes itself and in
the most pure form of that you can think
of a circle
right so to me an abstract version of
that model that you have over there
where you have you know the one person
and the other person
is this green this is green oh it looks
it looks black
or maybe a tiny smidge of green but all
right yeah i'll let it slow yeah you you
messed up my
but it's over yeah my color palette um
so the way that you have in that diagram
where you have you know
element one element two fusing to create
element three
which then fuses to create element you
know
to create element four and so forth is
the same concept as
you have this cycle right and this cycle
produces
an idea or it produces yes yes
and then this thing this cycle then goes
ahead and produces another item there
you go
right there you go follow it there you
have that in the middle right there you
go and that's a cycle
there you go and then you have another
idea and it's like this
but the funny part is this produced
maybe one maybe it produced two yep
yep maybe produced three that's right
that maybe this one fed off of and then
ended up producing
and you've made the flower of life yeah
exactly exactly that's where i was going
with exactly you know and then you have
all these points at which these things
you know they connect and it's it's a
big web
of just yeah awesome stuff yes that's
what it is it's
source is in essence creativity yes
yeah yes i i and i think that like
understanding that this is how the world
works right understanding that
going back to what i said earlier where
you're one force you can drive something
to a certain point
but then you're gonna get to a point
you're gonna you can drive something to
a certain point but then you're gonna
get to a point where
you need another circle you need another
one of these
and then this thing is going to create
another thing and then boom there you
have it we have that same diagram once
again right yes
so you need people you need the teams
you need all that good stuff in order to
create those driving forces that we were
talking about to begin with yeah yeah
that's right it it another way of um
that you're that you're inspiring me to
to think about this
is that and it's
it's really really really aligned with
what you're
doing you're with what you're sharing
here is that
it's like the
we have a cyclic we have a cyclic
cosmological process
that is very much so typically
expressed as this as this auroboros
the snake eating its tail and then
that process it's funny because this
entire process from what you could call
like you know the the big bang and then
the
you know the the evolutionary process
and then
evolution and then you have you know
humans
and then you have all of these like all
these insane
what are called fermi filters right here
which are like this last one is like
artificial general intelligence and this
one was like
um like nukes and asteroids
and uh anthropocene
anthropocene will will will add um
we'll add uh and
buy a war in that one in that top one
and then what's what's sort of what's
sort of interesting is like you're
describing
there's almost a
there's a there's an idea
and this is what you could call this is
kind of like the
the creative maybe process
and outcome of
this auroboros of the entire auroboros
and so you have
grabbing another color for us all right
so you have this
this beautiful big bang evolution humans
getting past the fermi filters to what
is called the
it's called the what's called the god
head
and then this is also referenced to as
the gateway
and then that's where you know we're
we're hypothesizing today that that's
the metaverse
and so that's the synthesis of agi you
know bio
slash neurotech and
the mixed realities and then
and so um so we're hypothesizing now
that
you go from big bang undergo this
massive evolutionary process get through
the fermi filters
get to this god head gateway metaverse
and then what happens is through this
process throughout this entire process
you've went through
and you've it's been a creative process
a journey all these hundred
billion humans 100 billion plus humans
that have lived and died
to build our world and have had these
experiences
and the outcome this entire cycle is
that idea
and then from this idea as
you know even it's funny because the
it's not just
ancient perennial spirituality now that
talks about this but even sir roger
penrose
the physicist that won the nobel prize
in physics in 2020
is very popular for cyclic cosmology
and so it's getting mainstream ladies
and gentlemen
it's getting main stream and so we have
just to
just to wrap on exactly what omar was
showing us
is that and then you go from this entire
creative process
from big bang to godhead and what
happens you go
another it's just the recursive process
on
it goes again so here's your snake tail
and there's evolving towards your god
head and then you're
undergoing the process again here's your
i here's your idea there's the creative
process and outcome
and so it's just this um you know
there's so many different ways to
articulate this
this point and that uh i just think that
this style of perception
being cyclic and being an
all-encompassing because you're not just
um you're not just synthesizing
perennial spirituality with cutting a
science
but you're also drawing out the uh the
physicalism narrative
of big bang too and then it's a big
question mark
and then we'll see what that is but
um the more that you sort of put on
virtual reality um the more you realize
that this already
is virtual reality so
all right well other uh other drawings
or or thoughts or is that
i think that pretty much covers that
covers basic gist of
how i i understand this i think that
a lot of people can see this differently
yeah but fundamentally what they're
trying to portray
is the same right it's just that people
have
different ideas or different ways of
visualizing
ideas and that everything is connected
even what we were just talking about
like with make plus yes yes
yes and like you know as someone might
use
rhino to explain what you just did yeah
yeah
and and you opted to go ahead and sketch
it on paper
i think all it does is it's it's a mode
of
of there's a vision in here i just need
to tell it to you i need to explain it
to you
yeah what's the best way to do that and
for me the circle
the god head this was a perfect perfect
way to put it
yeah yeah that was really well done by
bringing that
into our space yeah good job yeah good
job
that was nice i and these are this is
why when we're
hanging out you know two weeks ago when
i first came in that
i i do my absolute best to try and un
unleash this this the scent of the
flower
the essence of the soul is not limited
to the entrepreneurial the
the roots and the fruits and the moment
but it's also
it's metaphysics right and so to to
unpack that by asking
the the conscious agent
about what their thoughts are
about the nature of consciousness and
reality it elicits this
to arise of the scent of the flower but
it has to come
you know the the quality of your life is
the quality of your questions
so if you're going to ask people about
you know
the surface level stuff all day long
you're
that's going to be the quality of your
life but if you ask people questions
about the depths of the psyche and the
depths of reality and all this stuff
your quality of your life is going to be
that so questions are our queries into
the reality space
and i'll also add to that that like i'm
i'm pretty sure
i've thought about this countless times
like i've had this thought process
in my mind i've gone through it i have
an idea of
what i think the creative process
is and how things come about and how
things come to life but
actually being asked the question and
actually being
sort of put in that spot where i had to
verbalize it and then
let alone also diagram it this was this
was a great experience to really
understand it
you know like this this was this was
great
this one that's what we do i love that i
love that
so much and then i would say package
this experience into a
into a little heart and package it into
that heart
and then keep that heart with you
everywhere you go
and then when you're constantly creating
from that highest
from infinity from eternity
from cyclic cyclicity from your
absolute highest possible ethical moral
spiritual potential
everything else falls into place you're
constantly
reminded of that little heart package of
experiences like this
if you can take that to your friends to
people around you and begin
asking them what they think about it and
drawing things out sketching them out
showing them that little heart package
and then having them take it around with
them that's enlightenment
yeah yeah it's this it's the slow and
steady process of becoming more and more
enlightened consciously consciously
moving towards
becoming more and more enlightened right
yeah yes perfect
that was beautiful beautiful i love that
essence
you know one thing that i am very
interested in doing
on the program that i actually pretty
much haven't done at
all in 700 interviews is that
i haven't asked our guests like
questions
that i think are like silly hit me
okay i love the silly questions okay
cool cool um
i feel like i'm gonna regret that yeah
yeah i feel like i feel like you're
gonna love
actually this question um
so i would like to ask you about
oh lord walk me through walk me
walk me through your um
walk me through the process of
i'll just i'll give you some background
also i think it's really interesting
i don't know if anybody has ever seen
like the h3h3 podcast
and like uh ethan and hila klein ask
like
silly questions about like tell me about
how you like what's your ritual for
taking a poop
or like logan paul recently started
asking about like
you know how do you take your socks off
you know do you go do you take this
you use your right hand and take off the
left one first and then you take your
easier
then i can see you're thinking about how
you take off your socks and i i don't
know if i'm ready to share that but
no i'm kidding um
i usually just like i don't take i don't
actively take my socks off it's
something i've never actually noticed i
i usually just like
end up falling asleep with my socks on
and waking up without them
oh that's it that's yeah you're like on
autopilot
yeah yeah yeah and i think it's
something i probably do with like my
feet
yeah and that was that was uh casey
neistat's answer was that he goes
and he just puts his foot down and then
takes it off puts the other foot down
and takes it off yeah
i i can't consciously like recall my and
maybe it's because it's something that
you don't
yeah you're not aware of when you're
doing it it's so autopilot
you know that's a really good question
is that uh a good point is that for this
silly question i should be
um i should acknowledge that if i ask
someone about like
hey tell me about you know when you
drive a car it's like i knew you were
gonna say
i was gonna say that yeah because you're
you're on autopilot in your car man
that's i i know
yeah i knew you were gonna make that
yeah yeah and so maybe we should be more
like
where would we have a little bit more
conscious
awareness while we're doing something
that is something that's very relatable
for people like is is the shower
thoughts a good word
a good place to go like tell me about
like are you someone that takes a long
shower a short shower
um do you use shampoo conditioner and
body wash do you see this hair
does this look like a short shower to
you
i know you were telling me that the man
was a lot of work you're telling us
yeah i mean i i take i take really long
showers
um are we talking like 20 minutes 30
minutes
i think 20 to 30 minutes 20 to 30. yeah
there's i know there's a good 10 minutes
that i spend on my hair on just the hair
i could get into the details of that but
we will finish tomorrow
so um it's so it's it's shampoo and
conditioner in the house
and do you do twice or once uh no one
shampoo one condition one shampoo one
conditioner one shampoo one and each one
takes you five
because there's a lot of hair there's
also a lot of untangling that needs to
happen
every time every definitely every day
every time yes
yeah i mean my hair is very curly yeah
and so
it's it gets tangled up a lot and then
most of the times it's
it's also bunned up the way it is right
now um
so that just makes it tangle even more
so that there's like a good
five minutes worth of like i know i
never thought i'd be telling someone
this routine
alone on like we're doing it live
exactly
youtube i guess yeah yeah um but yeah
i'll go through the process
of of untangling most of it it shifts
sometimes depending on my mood i'll do
the shampoo and conditioner first and
then the untangling
or sometimes the untangling and then the
shampoo conditioner
but there's that and then there's i know
there's like a good
5-10 minutes you know washing up and
then there's like a good
five minutes of just clean just water
yeah and just take it yeah and just
clean it up
for me it's it's decompressing exactly
you know
like the hot water is that's right
washing away yes
today you know yes yes yeah oh do you
shower at night or in the morning
definitely at night yeah i mean my my
job
is that i uh you get hella dirty you get
i get dirty
exactly um so and then i think a lot of
the east follows that similar
principle of showering at night before
you get into your clean bed
whereas i think most of the west is
showering in the morning to wake up
right yeah right for me i
to me it's it's mostly the at night
because a
i'm and and again a i'm decompressing
yeah right yeah be more relaxed going to
bed and then b
is because i come home and i'm like
soaked and
you know sawdust and all other kinds of
stuff
do do you have to wash the
hair every night or can you skip one
night can you go every other night
if i'm if if if i go to the shop yeah
then i prefer to wash it every night yes
yes um
if i'm at home then i can skip a day
sometimes it's actually it's actually a
little healthier to let your
that's right to let it breathe with the
oils oils exactly yeah
um but i have to choose between do i
want my healthy oils or do i want my
unhealthy sawdust and
and all the other stuff that's right you
know that's right yeah so yeah
interesting silly questions i love more
yeah
that's good stuff i like the shower one
can you tell us what um
your shower thoughts are like
that's a that's a very bro broad one
because
if you're if i'm angry at you know for a
fact that i'm thinking about you in the
shower
you know i'm swearing at you i'm like if
i'm angry you know that's where
again like i'm decompressing so i'm
letting out
all the things that like it's that
private space
where you're sitting by yourself where
you're not really sitting by yourself
but like
it's it's mostly all the negative things
come out
and i address them in person sometimes
i'll talk
you know and get all of that sort of
negative energy out and wash it away
so there's that and then sometimes
there's it's a good place for me to just
brainstorm you know yeah so it's it's
it's
it's one or the other there's no other
thoughts besides anything random that
might come up but most of the times it's
it's the negative energy that i'm just
like
taking out or it's me brainstorming
something
and being in my own little bubble right
and then do you
have a little shower white board or do
you have a little notebook
or do you just go on your phone
afterward do you ever write down what
you do i don't
i don't write down shower thoughts i
don't i do not write down but that's
something that i might
i probably should start doing yeah some
of them are profound and you can act on
them and it's really important for that
future authoring north star
thing um how about uh do you
uh do do you remember your dreams
sometimes do you lucid dream do you take
control
of your character in the dream fairy i
can't i don't do it by choice
but there have been instances where i
found myself in control
a lot of times it's it's like there are
also a bunch of dreams where i'm lucid
but i'm not in control
yeah those are usually some of the
dreams that i'm i'm not very happy like
where you're being chased by someone or
a dude
i have a shitload of those yeah yeah i
have a [ __ ] loaded
i think there's an explanation to it
i've i've read it somewhere at some
point i i can't remember
traumatic familial lineage it seems to
be the most
epigenetic scientific also potential
uh answer to that can you elaborate on
that
just that epigenetics scientifically is
validating
that transgenerational
we can pass down uh dna uh
differentiations in dna methylation and
the histone tails which then
um can uh when spiritual people talk
about
ending trauma it means that there's an
actual
uh biochemical process that happens to
dna
that stops like if there's no more
physical abuse
it stops if there's no more
high levels of cortisol stress stress
stress it stops if you're not smoking
hella tobacco drinking alcohol it stops
right right and and so that's why it's
really important to be a [ __ ] good
parent
and uh to stop the transgenerational
trauma and so i think that um
the i think it's possible you know
this is possible but i think that
i think that families lineages that
have um
undergone um and this is most of the
planet actually
um i think i think the reason why people
have chasing
dreams of them being chased and uh
and being hunted assassinated killed
um extremely violent extremely fearful
that type of stuff i think has to do
with our
incessant perpetual war
that's very interesting um on
so to go back to the question i i mean i
i have i do remember my dreams
um i i dream frequently um
so a lot of my dreams i remember but
then choose to forget because
they're just like either something that
i've been overthinking or something that
is on my mind and i'm just like further
going through that thought process
in a more like mental form right
but a lot of times i'll find myself
waking up
and all i can think of is the dream
right i know some people actually like
to write down their dreams and they have
a dream journal and things like that
yeah i've tried that at a certain point
in my life and i i just realized that i
was filling it with a bunch of
crap like i dream a lot you know
it's a good thing i guess um but
on the other selectively pick what you
want to
you know fill with i feel it i feel mine
with everything for the last couple of
years and it's been really insightful
but i also understand that sometimes it
does feel like it's a completely
irrelevant thing to even write down
and so you can choose which ones to
write down and acts as a really
interesting reflection mechanism
especially when people try and do like
genealogical archaeology on
our lives down the line it'll be
interesting to
have these assets for them yeah right
yeah but then again
that being said i think i also like to
minimize how many things i need to do
before i get out of bed
right unfortunately we live in a world
where
the first before you even you know don't
do it never
never touch your phone never ever never
want to do it don't do it don't touch
your phone for an hour after you wake up
and don't touch your phone for an hour
before you go to bed
i completely and instead um reflect on
consciousness on your north star
on the divinity of life and you will be
a lot happier healthier
100 if you have a partner laying in bed
next to you
even more so talk to them yeah exactly
um yep
but yeah so dreams i mean i i also want
to just put out there that i do believe
that dreams are
one way of your mind sort of
understanding
what you're thinking about right so it's
one way for you to be able to
to visu it's wow it's like it's like
modeling
right it's like having a modeling
software but it's a very primitive
version yeah that's stuck in your head
right and it just like it operates by
itself whenever it wants and it just
shows you
a few things here and there yeah every
now and then to help you manifest the
idea
you know what i mean yeah so and that's
what model based reinforcement learning
is
also in computer science and machine
learning and artificial intelligence so
humans are mbrl model based
reinforcement learning agents we do
a lot uh in our dreams we do
a lot of that of running simulations
about
optimizing our reward functions and
that that's also what we do throughout
the day as well
um yeah and
we let's see if i can get this right the
monte carlo tree search
is where you simulate out then you ex
you simulate out from the
from the base node all the way out to
the leaf node and
then you expand it outward and then you
see that uh it's a good choice so you
select it
and then you go and do back propagation
and so
uh yeah select uh sorry simulate
expand um and then
you um there's the choice the selection
and then the back propagation
i think that's fascinating i think that
dreams play a massive role in that and
i want to ask you another silly question
which is
um i like so far we've we've done
showers and sleep which are interesting
and socks
yeah and socks yeah socks was i don't
know where logan got that from i like it
though socks is a good one too
yeah so sock shower sleep so triple s so
far
this one is an f what's your favorite
food
my favorite food um
it's a it's a middle eastern dish yeah
um
it's called yeah
what is it um it's basically a leaf um
it's a plant that you just dry out
really well
and then um there are there are so many
different ways to actually prepare it
yeah um but two of the more common ones
are where you
and it ends up ends up looking like
spinach yeah to an extent and you mix
chicken with it yeah and then you have
it with rice
that sounds real i love this it's it's
really really
really good like it's yeah what are the
spices what are the butters what did you
add
there's it's funny there's a spice
called seven spices yeah seven spices
that's it yeah
it's that what's that and then there's a
lot of cumin
cumin yeah i love cumin and a [ __ ] ton
of garlic
garlic me too bro i'm all about that
garlic right
so you you put those three things with
that leaf and a little bit of water it
turns into
more of like a soupish thing yeah um and
that sounds great bro
it's i i should make it let's let's
let's let's um
let's do it with uh maybe we do with
evan and we 100
yeah let's let's
[Laughter]
yeah maybe you should automate this at
some point yeah
[Music]
yeah um but yeah so that's
you know why we talk about it at the
beginning though is because whoever made
the introduction between the two get the
shout out
it does that genealogical archaeology
again so you know that
i get it you know the genealogy of where
the network the nodes got connected and
stuff
because otherwise you we we forget so
it's a really interesting thing to be
able to go back and recall at the
beginning of the episodes but
we should definitely make it and uh is
it a butter base
in the or what is it a olive oil or it's
olive oil olive oil yeah okay
cool i mean palestinians yeah it's
almost
always olive oil yeah yeah beautiful
that's awesome those are great those are
great uh answers now and it led us to
um uh a
man night you know it led us to a man
night so yeah a bro
night i'm pumped i i have to say not
that i didn't
enjoy most of it but this silly question
part
you should definitely do this for every
episode and i think you should probably
start with it
but you should start there break the ice
yeah and just like
yeah okay try it oh that's interesting
okay so start with silly questions to
break the ice
and then get into journey and then get
into it yeah because uh
yeah sometimes journey off the bat can
be dry and hard for people
um especially if they're sometimes
trying to get into some of the roots
and it can be hard but it also helps
make like people
know you better i feel like if i know
how someone puts their socks on i
already know them a little better
yeah um and it's weird because it has to
be balanced because there's also
something like
you know when you start off an episode
with um
you know maybe like um like
uh steve horvath uh and though um
his like epigenetic clock that he has
and i i reached out to try and get him
on the program
he's at ucla and i uh he said maybe
sometime
soon that he wasn't able to right now
but
that
sometimes it's also really not only
sometimes people don't want to answer
that stuff
but younger consciousness usually wants
to play and stuff it's fun
but also it's interesting that uh
it can sometimes be really powerful to
jump not
sometimes even skipping not silly
questions and not in journey
and just getting into like with someone
else like i think like if we have
um like sad guru on the program right or
someone that is a mystic or whatever uh
down the line when we have one it kind
of be interesting to just jump in like
let's go right into consciousness you
know that kind of a thing and that way
it's like boom
you're right there right the beginning
there was no warm-up
no no no footsies so there's like
balances and trade-offs of course to
this space but i like
i like that well let us know your
thoughts in the comments about the
uh the silliness and where you like it
in the program it's really cool yeah i'm
glad you
i just loved its presence yeah yeah yeah
yeah s socks uh
a shot three yes yeah yeah exactly socks
shower sleep food yeah
yep boom that's it
boom i love it it was a great episode
good job good job
thank you again for having me i i really
appreciate this opportunity
um and i hope that we actually did move
yeah this whole thing forward in essence
of what you're trying to do as well
yes um you definitely helped me
understand
what i and we are doing yes um
i hope that i've done the same for you
too absolutely
yes i love the smell of your flower
thank you i love i love the smell of
yours too thank you you can actually see
it i
was gonna see it there was that point
where you were talking you were making
that analogy about the flower and then i
was just looking at you for a second i
was like damn like
this guy this guy really thought about
it thought this entire thing through he
knows where he's coming from he's got a
visual representation
i love that that's good
smell that i would really love it if we
could uh almost like have a a soul scent
that could be interesting anyway anyway
soul sense
soulsense.com get the domain if you
haven't yet
uh maybe we'll call that our next
perfume i love
that yeah yeah yeah why not yeah you you
you heard it here folks
i'll be the first to try let's uh let's
let's go let's go take a quick look at
namecheap
just just for just for fun soul sense go
for it
let's just take a quick look what are we
on
boom it's registered in 2003
wow people jumped on that right away
looks like we weren't the first
uh shower thought on soul size
i love that that's funny what did they
did they build a website did anyone
actually do something can you try
you could look through it yeah yeah we
can go to it here and then we can go
take a look
let's see anyone do something with it
interesting or well yeah i mean they put
a little soulsense.com
soulsense.com is for sale click here to
inquire
4700
hey now that we talked about it check
that price again in a month
even believe it when i say it yeah i'll
see you when i say it
well that's a wrap folks we love you
very much thank you for tuning in
much much love we would
uh encourage you if you do live in the
los angeles metro area
get your booties down to make plus
and also hopefully
this inspires you to make
and undergo the maker's journey and
also to consider
the woodworking fab spaces recording
studios
photography music production studios in
your local
areas you know put those up get building
on those
and unleash some unique creativity in
your areas
and support the artists the
entrepreneurs
the spiritual leaders the scientists in
your communities and around the world
you can support us our links are below
support the people you believe in
you already know that let us know your
thoughts in the comments
subscribe if you haven't like the video
share it with other people
especially those that need to get going
on their entrepreneur creative dreams
and go and build the future everyone
manifest your dreams into the world we
love you very much
thank you again thank you very much
[ __ ] love it
much love peace peace